Comment faire plonger un sous-marin ?
Qu'est ce qui est vert et qui
vit sous l'eau ?
Un choux-marin !
Les sous-marins constituent un moyen detransport
fascinant ! Pouvoir explorer les profondeurs
glaciales des océans méconnus!
Mais comment font-ils pour plonger ?
Ils n'ont pas de nageoires comme les dauphins
ou les poissons et bien c'est ce que nous allons
voir avec l'expérience d'aujourd'hui. Je vais
avoir besoin d'une bouteille remplie d'eau,
d'un stylo enfin plus précisément du capuchon
d'un stylo, de ruban adhésif et de pâte à modeler.
La première étape va consister à boucher
le trou du capuchon avecle ruban adhésif.
Le principe c'est qu'il n'y ai
plus du tout d'air qui passe donc
on peut mettre plusieurs couches
de scotch, ce n'est pas un soucis.
Puis on va venir prendre une petite boule de
pâteà modeler qu'on va venir fixer
comme ceci sur le capuchon du stylo.
Une fois cela fait, on va venir
plonger le tout dans la bouteille.
La petite difficulté, c'est la taille de la boule
de pâte à modeler. Il ne faut pas que cette boule
soit trop grosse pour que le capuchon ne coule
pas tout de suite. Mais pas qu'elle soit trop
petite non plus. On va voir ça maintenant. On va
reboucher la bouteille puis on va venir appuyer
de toute nos force sur celle-ci. Et voilà, on
observe que le capuchon à coulé. Si on relâche
la bouteille, on voit que le capuchon remonte.
On appuie, il coule. On relâche, il remonte.
Si la boule de pâte à modeler était trop petite,
le capuchon aurait du mal à couler.
Au début de l'expérience le bouchon flotte car il contient
une bulle d'air qui le maintient à la surface.
En pressant la bouteille on appuie sur l'eau.
Cette eau va comprimer la bulle d'air qui diminue
donc de volume et ne peut plus faire flotter le
bouchon. Ce dernier coule alors entraîné par la
pâte à modeler. Quand on relâche la bouteille, la
bulle d'air peut prendre plus de place et va donc
entraîner de nouveau le bouchon à la surface
de l'eau. Les sous-marins utilisent ce procédé
pour plonger et remonter à la surface. Ils ont
des réservoirs qui se remplissent de gaz pour
remonter ou d'eau pour plonger. Ces réservoirs
sont appelés des ballasts. Beaucoup de poisson
possèdent un organe particulier : la vessie
natatoire. Celle-ci est une poche remplie de gaz
qui se contracte où se relâche en fonction de la
profondeur à laquelle se trouve le poisson. Ce qui
est un petit peu donc la même fonction que le
ballast.
Je t'invite à refaire cette expérience chez toi.
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode qui
est le dernier de cette saison.
J'espère que cette nouvelle série t'a plu. Elle a été réalisée en
se basant sur ces livres "Fais l'expérience"
aux éditions Apogée. Ce format étant nouveau
pour nous, des points reste à perfectionner,
n'hésite donc pas à écrire tes idées et remarques
dans les commentaires des épisodes.
Je t'invite à découvrir ou à redécouvrir les autres expériences
présentes sur notre site internet en cliquant sur
le lien dans la description ou sur la fiche juste
ici. Comme il en faut pour tout le monde, de
nombreuses conférences sont accessibles sur notre
chaîne YouTube pour en savoir plus sur diverssujets scientifiques.
Merci encore d'avoir suivi
cette série et à bientôt à l'Espace des sciences !